结了婚，
有了孩子，
这个家庭的话就这么几件事儿，
现有的这些资源怎么分配，
钱怎么花，
怎么安排，
精力怎么分配，
老人孩子谁来照顾，
就这几件事儿和男朋友不我发了一些矛盾，
我想让您帮我看一看我男朋友这个人我们两个适不适合在一起，
我是25，
他是26岁，
工作的话我是教师，
他是在一个国企，
他一个月到手一个W，
我的话是6K，
在一个二线城市，
我们两个的家庭都是普通家庭，
我家是有一个弟弟，
家里的负担除以我弟弟的负担较重，
但是我父母都有工作，
不是正式工作，
但是也能承担得起我弟弟的一些花费，
他们家庭比我们家条件好一些，
也是农村家庭，
但是之前做一些小生意，
不过他家里有一个比较有一些犹豫不决的一个因素，
就是他的父亲之前受了一些外伤，
伤到了腰上的一些神经，
所以行动有些不便，
这几年只能勉强扶着凳子走动一些。
我们双方父母的性格都是不算是拖累人的那种的，
我考虑到这个也是和他一直坚持了下来。
另外我们现在还有一个异地的问题。
这也不算多远，
距离40km吧，
我男朋友的性格比较勤快，
他也属于那种能分担家务，
也比较会照顾人的那种，
但是因为家庭的一些原因，
我男朋友在经济方面他也是表现的对我付出意识不是很强，
所以我有些介意，
前期我也是踩了一些累点，
让我们有一些跟他要东西什么的，
让我们矛盾比较多，
但是后期我们一直在交流，
感情方面都有一些改观，
我们两个人感情很好，
但是目前又出现了一个矛盾，
其实我觉得这个矛盾是本来就是可有可无的，
但是就吵起来了，
聊到了买房子的问题，
他们家的态度是出一个首付，
不写我的名字，
买到一个中间的位置，
后期的话，
他是打算他自己的公积金全部覆盖，
不用我出一分钱，
这个和他之前的一个承诺，
还有我们家可能比较传统的一个想法是不一样的，
虽然我也是了解一些婚姻法，
就写不写名字都无所谓，
但是我就比较介意他这个态度，
如果他写我的名字，
房贷什么的，
我也是乐意去和他承担的，
两个人的压力不算很大，
但是他就很抗拒这个东西，
我们在金钱方面也爆发过不少的矛盾。
在之前的。
时候其他的我比较介意的就是我回家的时候就一两次就回家会走访亲友嘛，
买一些东西什么的，
他可能会心里觉得有些介意，
嫌我花钱比较多，
花了是谁的钱，
他我自己的钱，
你花你自己的钱，
他也觉得你花钱太多了，
是吧？
对这里也有一个问题，
因为当时在我的工作的地方有个房租的问题，
他会觉得我自己连自己的生活都照顾不好，
还要给家里这样去弄东西，
关于这个房子我自己是有规划的，
但是他就认为我自己承担不起，
这个时候他内心里觉得可能我会花到他的这个钱，
所以当时他心里也有一些就是不能接受，
所以我就很纠结，
因为我们两个感情确实是很好，
有什么问题也是能够沟通的，
但是一旦遇到这些理上的一些问题，
就永远都是达成不了一致，
反正我也是有一些问题，
就包括我处他的累点啊，
或者是我的家庭确实会给他造成一些负担之类的，
你的家庭会有什么负担呢？
也没有什么负担，
考虑到可能未来会有一些负担，
因为父母都没有什么正式的工作，
未来可能有什么生病了什么的，
那他的父母有正式工作，
也没有这么双标吗？
对你。
标准这么高吗？
要求这么严格吗？
他就一直感觉就是如果首付的话，
他们家付我是受益人怎么样？
我不满意的点就是在于他总感觉我和他在一起是高他我他的意思说我不会吃亏，
因为他赚钱比我多，
就这一个点，
那么自信啊，
这男能这么自信啊，
他的优点有很就是跟他学历比我高，
他是个211的硕士，
长相也还可以，
个子挺高的，
而且他还表示过结婚的话他不会上交钱，
因为他炒点股，
所以他明确的表示说他有这个爱好，
以后自己的钱自己管，
共同开销是他来出，
但是我想去管他的钱了，
这基本上80%是不可能的，
他也表示过也有可能会让我试着去管这个钱，
但是大概率来说是不可能的，
姑娘你自己啊，
一个月能挣6000块钱，
能养活自己，
你要配得感高一点，
别那么自卑，
别那么卑微，
谢，
都不说别的，
光是他的爸爸腰受伤了，
行动不便这一点的话，
在我这儿就是一个很大的顾虑。
你觉得你老公会亲自去照顾他爸爸吗？
你觉你老公会花钱请保姆去照顾他爸爸吗？
你觉得大概率像你老公是不是有可能PUUA，
你让你去照顾他的爸爸是确实我。
他这时间比较在为差的，
对吧？
以你老公的调性的话，
第一他自己不可能辞职照顾他爸爸，
第二他不可能花钱请保姆照顾他爸爸，
只能牺牲你，
你自己做那吧，
啊，
是我跟你讲姐妹啊，
真正结了婚，
尤其是有了孩子，
柴米油盐神怎么花，
大声的现有的这些资源怎么分配，
就这几句话，
所有其他没结婚的姐妹你都给我往心里去，
结了婚有了孩子，
这个家庭的话，
就这么几件事儿，
现有的这些资源怎么分配，
钱怎么花，
怎么安排，
精力怎么分配，
老人孩子谁来照顾，
就这么几件事儿啊，
从我们外人的感受来说的话，
我们并不觉得这个男的有多爱你，
有多满意你，
有多爱乎你，
是我自己也是有这种感觉，
总是你来啊，
我的家庭就是，
我不知道怎么去调和我和家庭之间的一些矛盾，
我们家里就是，
嗯，
我觉得正常人说很大的利益偏向于弟弟，
我也可以接受，
但是家里的就我妈妈，
他们会对我有一些PUA，
其实我感觉普通家庭的这些情况也比较正常，
但是有时候会感觉自己不能接受这些事情，
比如说举个例子，
他们PUA你什么呢？
之前也表达过我自己不想结婚这件事，
他们就会感。
人，
我随便给我找个理发的，
觉得说我家比孩的好也就行了，
其他的就是我记得印象比较深的一件事，
我妈妈跟我说，
谁说谁对谁家的女儿不好，
不好说人家这个大被子给他做的，
这不是也很好吗？
怎么样？
所以我有时候就感觉心里确实是不能接受，
是这样子的啊，
如果你的爸爸妈妈他们的生活状态，
他们的生活的节奏啊什么的，
你不喜欢，
那尽量离得远一点，
听人生经验一定是听那种他的生活状态，
你可太羡慕了，
人生经验一定是听这样的人的人生经验，
你自己是受过教育，
你自己能挣6000块钱一个月，
你能养活自己，
能养活自己就是一个自己有选择权的前提，
因为在现有的法制框架下，
没有人敢五花大绑绑着你去领结婚证，
没有人敢给你关到房间里面让你跟谁同房，
是不是啊，
就所有的角色都在我自己身上，
要硬气一点，
姑娘啊，
硬气一点，
能养活自己就是一个很棒的一件事情，
谢谢老这些，
我可能是没有谈过恋爱吧，
总感觉分手是一件，
可能是太依赖了，
该是不谈几个，
谈个3个2个的，
3个4个的都可以保好自己的钱，
保护好自己的身体啊，
尤其是女孩子啊，
跟任何一个男人睡觉之前的话，
一定是所有该检查的。
丈母所有该核实的点都要核实完了，
不要稀里糊涂跟任何一个人比较啊，
不要把男人的那种欲望当成是爱，
不是的，
男人的爱是他会为你的利益去考虑，
他会从你的角度去考虑问题，
那个才叫爱。
好好的说明白了，
好，
谢谢老师，
拜拜，
嗯，
记得点赞关注哦。